the question is what do you believe
do you believe that you are worthy of
happiness nothing upsets people so much
as to hear about their friends making
money i mean that that's very
destructive to discipline because they
think i'm smarter than that guy next
door and he just just bought that new
car with the money made trading stocks
on the internet so why can't i you were
just a college dropout you were very
young looking did you get taken
seriously by businessmen who are much
older want wanna be happy build a life
not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside youtube
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think to get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one believe that you are worthy with
oprah winfrey for me colored girl
negro child
growing up in mississippi
that one of the greatest gifts i was
ever afforded was not to have been put
in a segregated school system
had i been put in a segregated school
and taught in a segregated school system
that said you're less than because
you're a woman and you're less than
because you're a colored woman
i probably wouldn't be here today i
would have had to then overcome that
belief that conditioning of a belief but
because i was raised by a grandmother
who
raised me in the church
and
i went to church
sunday school um
lived in the church
and i would sit there
second pew
on the right
third row
every sunday just taking it all in and i
would listen to the stories listen to
the bible stories and i would hear
that
through god all things are possible
i would hear the story of jesus talking
about
if you have the faith of a mustard seed
and you know as many years later that i
actually
saw a mustard seed i could not believe
what a mustard seed actually looked like
have you ever seen a mustard seed here i
have some here
i want to pull one out now jesus said if
you had the faith of a mustard seed you
could move mountains
and anything was possible now i heard
this as a kid and i really believed it
and so the question is what do you
believe
do you believe that you are worthy
of happiness do you believe that
happiness success
abundance
comfort fulfillment peace
joy
love is a part of your birthright
is that what you believe
or do you believe something else because
you will
manifest
the life that you believe
i've always known that no matter what my
belief is i'm going to be all right why
because i have that faith of a mustard
seed rule number two don't get itchy
with warren buffett there can be all
kinds of wonderful investment
opportunities out there that i don't
understand i don't know what cocoa beans
are going to do next year you know maybe
you know but i don't know i i don't know
what i don't know what crude oil is
going to sell for
but
i don't have to know
i just have to know the things i have to
know what i know
i have to know where the limits of my
understanding are
what i call
what my circle of competence is
and if i'm only able to evaluate five
percent of the businesses in the world
no problem i just stay within that five
percent and try and find something
uh and that's most people get in trouble
because
in investments because they
uh well they get itchy you know they
can't discipline themselves and they
hear about other people making money
nothing upsets people so much as to hear
about their friends making money i mean
it's that that's very destructive to
discipline because they think i'm
smarter than that guy next door and he
just just bought that new car with the
money made trading stocks on the
internet so why can't i well the answer
is you can't over time you will lose
money if you trade stocks actively
and uh
it's it's hard to exercise the
discipline
but anytime you buy something
you should be able to take out a
one-page sheet of paper
and say i'm buying general motors it's
65 i'm buying general electric 150
because
and you should write down the reasons if
you can't if you can't fill out the
sheet
if it's because somebody told me about
it at a cocktail party last night that's
not good enough if it's because my
broker told me about it that's not good
enough
yeah it's uh you've got to have a reason
for thinking that it makes an
intelligent investment you do the same
thing if you're buying a farm or an
apartment house if you're buying a farm
you'd say i'm buying this farm with a
thousand dollars an acre because i think
i can earn sixty dollars an acre on it
if corn sells it such and such and
soybean cells and such and such and
yield as such and such
and you'd figure it out
that's the same reason you buy
businesses and when you buy stocks
you're buying a little piece of a
business
and that's probably the most important
thing to remember in in investing is
that when you're buying a stock you're
buying a little piece of the business
and
if you are buying it at an attractive
price for the business for the whole
business you're gonna make money and if
you aren't
you know over time you won't make money
rule number three persevere with bill
gates you were just a college dropout
you were very young looking did you get
taken seriously by businessmen who are
much older for some people that youth
uh
and
geekiness uh was like hey
should we trust them you know that's so
weird we've never seen something like
that before so yes we had to fight for
acceptance i couldn't rent cars uh so i
had to take cabs around because i was
too young and you know probably some
people were a little tough but
then as as we got a little bit of
success
people were fascinated by this deep
belief we had in in software lesson
number four define commitment with grant
cardone i think people need to define
what commitment is for me when i commit
to something the next two things that
will happen is it will be on a schedule
requires time and i will invest some
money
all commitments
for me require time and money
if i don't write a check i'm not
committed
if i don't have if i don't take time out
of my calendar i'm not committed so if i
want to work out okay my body started
starting to cause me some problems right
so i'm like i'm committed to taking care
of my body
what did i do wrote somebody a check
show up in my freaking place every day
at seven o'clock
and i'm gonna work out okay that was
four months ago i've missed five days
in 120 days
that's commitment time and money hey man
how you doing buddy good how are you you
got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out
where can people get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael he's got a new
book out build a serve go grab it today
at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five have the right objective
with elon musk we're focused on like
that it's it's important to have that
that have the objective be right
um
that's why i was talking so much about
the importance of making him off mars a
self-sustaining is building a
self-sustaining city on mars
um if if that's the objective then
obviously
you know just putting some satellites in
orbit or
is not that that's not important you
have to achieve full and rapid
reusability amp size full and rapid
reusability is only relevant to the
degree as rapid and complete
and
and then you also have to do orbital
refilling this is essential as well
um
and uh and then um
propellant production on mars also
essential
so
uh
you know and
with that as the goal then
you know that that means that that
creates i think a good forcing function
for
radical innovation because in the
absence of radical innovation we have no
chance of meeting that goal
um
whereas if i go simply you know
defeat lucky to boeing or something like
that
that
we were probably
achieving already done it
it was that really wasn't even a thing
you know i wish it was
um
yeah like they're not really trying to
do not even trying to do reusability
which is bizarre because they make
planes that are reusable
um
so
i mean if they if they talk to their
like you know if they talk to one of
their customers about bias or
a lucky fighter jet or a boeing aircraft
like hey we're going to sell you a 737
it can be used once
and it's not 737 max
but that was that turns out that was a
single user plan at times um but it it
really uh
it would be an absurd thing for them to
sell a
single use aircraft but they feel quite
comfortable selling a single-use rocket
um
and anyway but if our goal is simply
we're gonna have to be the leaders in
uh launching the conventional satellites
that exist uh we would probably
approach that in on a sort of a
logarithmic basis where
you know you get there and you sort of
slowly make progress towards doing
10 launches a year 12 launches a year
and while they do six or something like
that
um
but since the goal is hey we need to
make life multi-planetary before it's
too late
um and time really matters
so
we're
our states also it's like we're shooting
for mars not just the moon it's not much
suit for the moon shoot for mars
and then and then the you know these
these competitive things are kind of
small things along the way unless
somebody else is shooting for mars they
will not be competitive with something
as
pedestrian as launching a few satellites
into earth orbit rule number six
eliminate waste with jeff bezos one of
the key
things about lean
you know defect reduction being
efficient not letting defects travel
downstream in any process if you're
going to eliminate waste or as the
japanese call it muda
you have to
have information
and
the data center has historically been
an information free zone as far as
application developers are concerned
you would write code
and you have no idea
how it's consuming resources you're too
insulated
because you're in a pool of resources
and you can't meter it
one of the biggest still
unappreciated
benefits of aws
is that application developers
get a real sense
of which inner loop is driving all the
cost
yeah
and that's a big deal
so that and that's just starting to
that's one of the ways that
that this approach to uh infrastructure
dramatically reduces costs in our in our
data center i mean in our fulfillment
centers and in our customer service
centers we have
we're always seeking to keep defects
from moving downstream so this is a
you know
a principle that was probably best
applied in the early or best first best
applied
by toyota
um and they had this idea of what they
call the andon cord which basically any
factory worker could pull the cord and
stop the whole automobile manufacturing
line
and
for old school
auto manufacturing companies that was
considered crazy
absolutely insane in fact the opposite
principle was typically at work which is
you did everything possible to keep that
line running
and here toyota flipped that on its head
and they said look
anytime there's a defect no matter how
small they want you to pull the cord and
stop the whole line
[Music]
and um
stopping things you know if you if you
do that in a line that has a lot of
defects initially you get a lot of end
on cord pulls and it's very expensive
and but over time if you use that
approach you eliminate the defects
closer and closer to the source
and
and the people who are
fans of
lean manufacturing and these kinds of
techniques
take almost as an article of faith
although there's a lot of evidence to
support this in very diverse industries
that the further a defect travels
downstream
the more expensive it becomes to fix
and so you want to you want to stop
those things you don't want them to
repeat and happen over and over and rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is have
self-awareness with mark cuban you've
never been shy to speak up in issues
that are important to you yep and one of
those themes i've found has been around
fairness and whether that's you know
calling out referees for not calling
games consistently or you know calling
out a shark tank contestant because you
think that they're scamming their
customers how do you decide
what you're going to speak up on or do
you hold inside you know it's changed
over the years um because i have kids
because social media you know twitter in
particular is so much different
and it's changed kind of the rules of
engagement
um
it's changed because of what i went
through with the mavericks last year i
missed a sexual harassment problem that
we had because i wasn't i took my eye
off the ball um
and so you know i try to be self-aware
and try to put myself in the shoes of
the person or people or organization i'm
talking about whether it
adds value um i try to put myself in the
position my own position you know how's
it going to be perceived and you know is
it worth it you know will it create more
good
than
challenges right and and so you've got
to pick your spots now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week the science
says that when you just watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following through on
your goals 35 that's not enough that's
not enough just to get motivated believe
nation we're here you're here today
matters you're an action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
if i leave you with nothing else it's
just know this for sure
there is not one
thing
that has ever happened to you
not one experience
not one encounter not one crisis not one
joyful thing that hasn't
happened
just to make you better and help you
rise
every single thing you're calling in
whether you know it or not when you
figure out that you are calling it in
when you actually start meditating or
praying or doing or having a spiritual
practice which is the number one thing
you need if you want to be successful in
the world you need something that gives
back and nourishes you
regardless of what you call that you
need to you need to fill your cup so
that you can be so full your cup runneth
over and you have enough to give to
other people if you don't fill your cup
you end up dried up
you end up tired exhausted and don't
have enough to give to other people you
end up resentful every time somebody
asks you because your cup is empty and
now they want some of yours
so your number one job your number one
job is to fill
your cup
and
make yourself
whole
that's your job i decided to to focus
more on
uh giving away than than making money
and so i've uh gotten a chance to travel
the world be out in africa and asia
quite a bit and see the needs that are
out there and now our foundation is very
focused on global health
focused on agriculture because the
majority of the the very poor in the
world are farmers who have very small
plots of land so any increase in
productivity or certainty of their crop
coming in
can make huge difference for them
and you might think of a career in
software
you know selling to
people who can afford personal computers
and now the career at the foundation is
being very different we felt a little
bad i i certainly i did about leaving
the university
when
uh i thought very interesting work on
artificial intelligence was really on
the verge of taking place and
symbolically proving programs were
correct ironically now you know it's
taken a long time the rate of progress
which is hard to make numeric
in both those areas has been quite
modest i mean we haven't gone backwards
or anything but ai is turned out to be a
tougher problem which is is fascinating
and now there there are some interesting
advances and likewise symbolic
type things there are some now advances
so we thought we'd miss
uh being more at the center of those now
through at least funding microsoft
research we get to
have some
level of involvement in that
one of paul's ideas was to build a 360
emulator that was the dominant mainframe
of the time use bit slice uh
architecture to just you know blow away
the pricing on
mainframe computing but we decided that
was kind of boring uh compared to
personal computing a company came along
about five years later two pi and did it
uh they didn't do the software piece
right that's why they failed because we
still think it was a good idea but we
didn't have anything even close to hey
let's build a computer that we want to
use that we want to have as a tool for
our own
messing around and communication and
creativity that
that kind of got at the center of our
thinking even from
the early days one of the precursors one
of the foundational things
to being able to take risk is to have
had
some kind of support from somebody you
have to have some mentors
you have to have somebody who loves you
these are the kind of things that build
up and allow you
to kind of you know jump off into
uncharted terrain and do something new
because you know you have
a support system of one kind or another
and uh and i certainly did so
for me i just want to point out that i i
i feel very strongly that
um
there's a lot i've won a lot of
lotteries uh amazon is one of the
lotteries that i've won but i had a big
lottery with my parents my dad is a
cuban immigrant he came here when he was
16 years old didn't speak any english
uh my
his is a great guy and my
mother
had her
had me when she was 17 years old so she
was a pregnant 16 year old in
albuquerque new mexico in high school
which was not cool
and
she made it work and her her parents my
grandparents helped her with that whole
thing and made made that all work and if
you don't get that kind of support
somehow it doesn't have to be your
parents sometimes people get lucky it's
a grandparent or it's a friend or a
family friend or a teacher it can be
somebody but you need that somebody has
to step into your life and that's a
lottery that i suspect a lot of people
in this room have also won just like me
okay so you're running you're ceo of two
companies you're chairman of solar city
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep
uh
yeah sometimes not enough sleep is
really great uh because
because if i find if i don't get enough
sleep then i'm i'm quite grumpy
um
i mean obviously i think most people are
that way
and and and also
um like i try to sort of figure out
what's the right amount of sleep
because like i found i could have
i could drop a certain threshold of
sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it that would
get less done because
my
mental acuity would be affected
so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours on average per night um that's not
too bad yeah right and any other tips on
average though
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously i mean do
you do you find i mean i know you're up
here monday tuesday is it all tesla when
you're up in silicon valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a
service having a smartphone is
incredibly helpful because that means
you can do email during
interstitial periods like you're in a
car you're walking in the bathroom
everywhere you can do email practically
when you're awake
and uh
and so that's really helpful to have
email for spacex and and tesla
integrated
on my phone
um
and then uh
and then just you have to apply a lot of
hours to actual working actually working
so the way i generally do it is i'll be
working at spacex
on monday and then monday night flight
to the bay area
spent tuesday
and wednesday at the bay area
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night spent thursday and
friday
at spacex
um in in the last several months then i
would fly back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
or
spend saturday at tesla and sunday at
spacex don't stop looking for a job now
right just because things are difficult
doesn't mean you know that there's not
opportunity there because all it takes
is one
if you just if if you grind it out and
you continue to be persistent whether
it's emailing calling you know setting
up on seminars whatever it may be
however you can connect with people
applying for jobs to wherever however do
it you know every note gets you closer
to a yes and all it takes is that one
opportunity to propel you to where you
look to be
and you know and i guess adding to that
again like i said earlier there there's
so many new things going on when you
know when i came out of college way back
when um the was the last time that
unemployment was in double digits you
know my friends you know i remember
reading a story i went to indiana
university talking about how the
unemployment rate in northern indiana
was 20
and you know my friends were freaked out
like kids are today and i had to be
mobile right i had to go from indiana
back to pittsburgh my home down to
dallas in order to really get to a job
that i could platform and so as you look
for these things
you you really have to be more
adventurous if you will and be more
mobile and be more flexible and agile
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
you don't have to get the best job you
don't have to get a perfect job you just
have to get a job and now all of a
sudden you're getting paid to learn and
you can platform that just like an mba
free agent right it might spend one year
or two year at one two years at one team
build their skill set to get better and
go to a better situation looking and
finding a job looking and finding an
internship looking at building your
skills set to prepare yourself for what
comes next
there's no better opportunity than now
first of all when we interview people we
we do ask for some evidence of
exceptional ability which in most cases
includes innovation
uh this is not said everyone needs to be
innovative it's
but we certainly need those that are
doing advanced engineering to be
innovative
um
and ideally everyone is at least some to
some degree innovative
so at the
interview point
we
select for it for people who want to
create new technology
and then the incentive structure
is
set up that such that
innovation is rewarded um making
mistakes
along the way does not come with a big
penalty
um
and but but failure to try to innovate
at all comes with a big penalty
you'll be fired okay
yeah all right the carrot and stick
that's the steak if you don't even try
um or or
somebody doesn't even try to debate or
their innovation um aspirations are are
very are
not not very good
then
yeah they will no longer be at the
company one of the things that i think
we've done well
is is just given the people at the
company a lot of opportunity right so
you know it's not just me who started
when i was 19 and and now you know i'm
running this big company there were a
number of people who joined
who were you know people i did problem
sets with at harvard or they dropped out
of stanford or you know different
programs who have grown with the company
over this long period of time and you
know one of the things that i'm the most
proud of is we have
about 12 different product groups at the
company
and
all of the people who are running them
um
with the exception of
one
did not join the company running a
product group or reporting to me that's
amazing um and the one exception was
is david marcus who was the ceo of a you
know 50 billion dollar public company so
um you know so i'm pretty happy that
that he's on board and having him run a
product group i think is a pretty big
coup too but literally none of them
started off reporting to me um you know
they all start off in different
different roles some were engineers some
were data analysts um some were product
managers and they've all grown but i
think what happens is you know people
see that you create opportunities for
people and and that also i think keeps
the best people engaged and makes the
best people want to come work at your
company because they feel like oh i'm
going to get those kind of opportunities
too it's really important to
differentiate yourself i say that more
than anything you've got to get to the
point and you've got to give the what's
in it for them very concisely and very
quickly so with with differentiating
yourself i'll use an example i always
say you've got to differentiate you've
got to tell the person or the world why
you're unique and why you're different
very clearly and concisely then you have
to let them know why you're unique and
different in comparison to other options
they may have and then you need to let
them know why that matters to them
so
i'll use my own journey and just give
you the example i also say it's really
important to sell the problem you're
solving not just the product
so i'll take my spanx so when i first
invented spanx if i were to plug in this
equation and how important it was the
first thing i said to the buyer or
anybody if i was in the media if i got a
chance to be on the news i would say
do you have you know you know how women
have things hanging in their closet that
we have no idea what to wear under
and then they would nod and so i
immediately started with the problem
creating the problem that i'm now about
to solve then i would say and then you
know how our underground options they're
not that great you have regular
underwear that leaves a panty line that
you can see or these very thick heavy
duty girdles that are too thick under
your beautiful clothes or your nice
slacks and leave lines on your legs
okay then i've just given them the
options that are dysfunctional and then
i tell them well i've just invented this
product and look what it does it meets
in the middle of the options that are
out there and here's why it's going to
be important to you here's why it's
going to matter you're going to be able
to wear white you're going to be able to
wear cream you're finally going to be
able to wear all the fabrics in your
closet that you don't wear anymore and
you're gonna you're gonna look amazing
you're gonna have no lines so then i
would give the what's in it for them but
that's just a quick example and i would
always i like to start with the problem
that i'm solving have them just sort of
invest in it with you
and then um why the other options aren't
so great people need to know from you
you're the only one that can do it why
you're their best choice
don't don't assume that they're going to
just try to figure it out people are
busy people are you know we got a lot on
our mind tell me even in an interview
when i'm interviewing people i want them
to say i'm your best candidate and
here's why amazon one of the things we
try to do
is have multiple paths to yes
and so here's here's a little thought
experiment for you
if you are
a junior
executive at amazon
and that if amazon did this in the
typical kind of corporate hierarchy way
you had an idea
you need to get your boss
to green light that idea and then your
boss's boss needs to green light that
idea and then your boss's boss's boss
needs to greenlight that idea they're
probably five levels or more
before that idea gets the go-ahead
assume instead that you're an
entrepreneur with a startup company idea
and you need venture capital
you go to sandhill road and you go to
the first venture capitalist and they
tell you no
and you go to the second one and they
tell you no
you're maybe your 20th one tells you yes
you've got 19 no's and one yes
and you're still good to go
so that
that venture capital model is there's
multiple paths to yes there were 20
people who could give you a yes and it
didn't matter how many gave you a no so
if you want innovative thinking
you have to think about how can we get
you want height a large number of high
judgment people empowered to green light
things
you want multiple paths to yes you want
a system where as a junior
air force officer with a good idea
the first five people tell me no and
somehow i can still go pursue that idea
so you got to figure out that's an
organizational
challenge
that big organizations have to figure
out a way to do and by the way
i get you know
this happens all the time i'll say i
don't think that's a good idea but
somebody else will greenlight it and i'm
fine with that because usually
the cost of the experiments is pretty
small things only get expensive when
they work
right once something works you're like
whoa we need to double down on that now
and then the spending can get heavy and
then those become big consequential
decisions and that's where the hierarchy
and the
using the judgment of the most senior
people to me this really helps when
you're down and out first thing people
do is blame it on everybody else but
themselves
when you start taking responsibility you
have a little different outlook you also
have the responsibility of turning
things around when i started paul
mitchell i was homeless once again
totally by accident
and i i started the company out of the
back seat of my car how were you at that
time 37 that was 34 35 at that time so
you're homeless at 34 35 again
and what was this series of events that
led to that second time it was just that
we had money set up a half a million
bucks we need to start the company with
that kind of money and uh the day i was
ready to start go down the bank and get
the money my partner the hairdresser
paul mitchell flew her from hawaii with
his girlfriend and we were ready to get
the money and get going and get started
i'd left everything i did my
relationship wasn't working out so left
the house plenty of money for many
months with her had a few hundred bucks
in my pocket took the used car which is
20 years old but a decent one okay down
the hill to get the money wow i was
going to check into an efficiency and
all set up the money never came in no
way nev the guy changed his mind 1980 81
inflation in the united states is 12 and
a half percent
interest rates if you could get a loan
prime rate
17
wow we stayed in line to get gasoline
and interest uh and unemployment was ten
and a half percent the united states the
guy said you're his hostages are still
in iran which they were at that time he
says is this a terrible i'm sorry it's
the last minute no
so as a matter of
what are we going to do the key thing
was that paul allen and i
had loved working on software since we
were lucky enough to be exposed
literally i was 13 and 8th grade when
this time sharing terminal came in and
we just did it day and night and you
know got better and we could see
that the magic of software combined with
this miracle of the microprocessor
subject to moore's law exponential
improvement that that was a magic
combination and we we'd look around and
say hey how come everybody's not
saying this is amazing i mean we're
gonna dethrone ibm and uh you know why
doesn't digital equipment get it why is
the guy who runs it this is a company
that's long gone uh but dominated many
computers at the time why isn't that guy
up there saying it's it's wrong we know
it's right and so the key event for us
was it was a very cold boston winter
and a kid computer came out on uh this
popular electronics magazine and we said
oh
this is happening without us i mean here
we are
uh
doing nothing
and so we called the company up and said
you know hey we're ready uh
and then we called them back we actually
did the work and then we called them
back and said how do you make the stuff
go in and out of the computer the i o
and they said well that's interesting
nobody else has ever asked that you must
really be doing something so that was
anyway our very first customer and so we
grabbed on to it to be the very first
and we were the first to say there
should be a software industry and come
and do it in a sense it was one of the
lower risk things i've ever done in my
life i had a guy the other day asked me
for some advice
okay you know these people that ask for
advice i know you know you give it to
them and they they don't do it yeah
he knew it was true it hit him
he's like i know that's right and then
he went and did something different this
is a big mistake people make man things
the best things that have happened to me
did not require
any more thought
the best decisions i've made in my life
were instant
so like my wife and i like when i've
decided to buy something i go buy it i
don't check with her because that adds
thought it adds time
and and
this is another bad piece of advice i
was given like take time
think about it don't move too fast take
baby steps
uh you don't know nobody on this planet
ever took baby steps
they went fast
and and the faster you can go you know
my plane is safest when it's up in the
air when it's landing slowing down is in
trouble when it's taken off it's it's at
risk that's interesting at flight at
full speed it's almost the safest thing
wants to fly
you know and and people people are being
conditioned to slow down think about it
take your time take a drug i was put on
lithium when i was 20 29 years old
because the the psychologist thought i
needed to slow down
she was scared of speed
i wouldn't and at that time were you
doing well financially or doing i was
doing great but everybody was saying hey
you're doing too much of this and you're
doing too much of that and you're going
to burn and you're going to do this and
people were worried about me around me
they were going slow i was vibrating
faster than they were
but a hummingbird vibrates bumblebees
vibrate right they do things that are
impossible
so
you don't want to slow down
and and you want to move with speed and
certainty that means people need to know
what they're doing
if i know what i'm doing that's why
confident people tiger won today talking
one today he'd been fighting man been
efforting 10 years he hadn't had a win
he won today that guy moves with speed
and certainty think in order to actually
do the stuff yes money is important but
i also think the thing that i hold the
dearest and the reason why
uh
uh the noise about running for president
moved me so
uh
humbly and deeply is because it means
that you have somewhere in the work
gain the people's trust yes and there is
nothing more important to me than having
the trust of the people and the audience
and i i mean i recognize that it is the
audience who came every day and watched
you know from all over the world that
actually
yes that that helped me to be who i am
so i think the uh the the renowned the
the the standing
the the ability to be trusted and to say
something but also listen don't play the
billionaire thing small don't play the
beast mall yeah it's it's a very big
deal because it allows you to
it allows you to
it allows you to actually do the work so
instead of saying gee i would like to
help so many people or you should go out
and help so many people you can actually
use that for yourself and i am now at
this stage of my career thinking about
how to do that
more poignantly and fruitfully i'm now
looking for ways that i can do that to
create a level of sustainability in
within our communities what do you say
to employees when
you have obviously have some traders in
the stock who are not happy and suddenly
the stock is down 25 after a quarter
well i so
for well since 1997 at almost every all
hands meeting we have two all hands
meetings a year
at almost every all hands meeting i
remind
employees
that you know if the stock is up 10 this
month don't feel 10 smarter
because when the stock is down 10 some
month you're gonna have to feel ten
percent dumber and it's not going to
feel as good
and so it's you know ownership
is uh we give most of our compensation
uh is is done in terms of
stock compensation
and
and part and parcel with ownership is a
mentality of of long-term thinking you
know you
owners think longer term than renters do
so i have a friend who rented his house
to some tenants and instead of getting a
christmas tree stand at christmas they
just nailed the christmas tree into the
hardwood floors
of the house no owner would ever do that
and um but sometimes that's a bad tenant
you know they're a good good tenants but
that's a bad tenant and it's because you
know this is the same old thing about
you know nobody ever washed a rental car
and um
you you take better care of the things
that you own and and uh
but but one of the responsibilities of
ownership
and definitely deep inside the amazon
culture is to think about the
fundamentals of the business and not the
daily fluctuations in the stock price
it's no there's no information in it so
what is your decision making process or
thinking when it comes to investing your
time your money your energy sure uh it's
very important because time is the most
valuable thing you have is one make sure
where you're putting your time and
energy
is something you want to do
not just because you're exploring with
people you don't like or a business you
don't like or a situation you don't like
time is so valuable try and speak if
you're speaking to people or a situation
to people you feel there's hope for that
you can do something with to do
something great not just make money
whenever you go into business or in a
relationship with someone just to make
money then it means you've already
decided to take a portion of your time
to make these papers that are backed up
by nothing but will buy stuff
to call it a possession
we have all these great possessions well
if you have these great possessions
could you give them away
if you had any possession you could give
it away hey great it was a possession
and you moved on if you can't give that
possession away to somebody
just give it away then it possesses you
leadership is not only about inspiring
leadership is those people who join your
company
you have to create value for him you
have to making sure in three years he'll
be different
not because his job is different because
if the people not different the products
will never be different
i told many people when they joined
alibaba i say guys i don't know
fortunate or unfortunate to enjoy
alibaba
we work much longer than the others
much harder
we had more problems than most of the
companies
if you can survive in alibaba you can
survive at any company in the world
because life is tough
we never promise
you will be rich
you'll be successful you will probably
promote it
but we will promise you
you will be a problem
you have a wrong
you will make a mistake you have a
terrible boss
we all promised
so you set the expectation
but have a good vision
so that is the way we manage
the company
and i think
when you hide good people the good
people
believe the vision they will go so when
i visiting a company whether it's a good
ceo or not i do not listen to the ceo
i listen to his people
if the people believe the vision
all the people believe this guy
if the people believe the vision
if the people believe this guy this
company has hope
a good
a good entrepreneur
can always tell good stories
i don't need to listen story from you
guys
i can tell your people
right if your people
any young people in your company he can
tell me the vision
he can tell me what they're doing
that is a good company
that's leadership leadership making sure
everybody when they sleep
when they drink when they talk when they
go to toilet they talk their vision and
they believe it and generally
you want to embark on something it's
desirable to figure out if success is at
least one of the possibilities right
exactly
because for sure failure is one of the
possibilities yes um but but ideally you
want to try to
bracket it and say success is in the
envelope of outcomes yeah um
and i wasn't quite sure if that was the
case um i mean i think success on an
academic level would have been quite
likely because you can publish some
useless paper and uh
most papers are pretty useless um you
know we have a few don't take a photo
sorry yeah i mean
how many php papers are actually used by
someone ever um i mean no it's a good
point percentage-wise it's not it's not
good yeah uh
and
so
so it could have been one of those
outcomes where
uh you add some
leaves to the tree of knowledge yeah
okay um and and that leaf is nope it's
not possible
like all right
they go seven years a month
[Laughter]
so that what so that was one path and i
was prepared to do that but then the
internet was the error came along and i
was like okay the internet i'm pretty
sure success is one of the possible
outcomes and it seems like i could
either do
do sort of do a phd and watch the
internet happen or i could participate
and help build it in some fashion you
know put
you know
like i just couldn't stand the idea of
watching it happen yeah yeah so that
that's uh so i decided to put things on
hold uh and
start an internet company well i was
lucky that i got started early i mean
always helps if you get started early
and
and my dad happened to be in investment
business so i would go down his office
on
saturdays and so at age probably seven
or something i started reading these
books that were around the place and
so i had a
15-year jump on many people in a sense
and that that helped a lot and and i was
always fascinated by them i knew what i
wanted to do early and i think that's a
that's a huge advantage too
and then
you don't need you don't need a lot of
brains in this business i mean i've
always said if you got an iq of 160 give
away 30 points to somebody else because
you don't need it in investments what
you do need is emotional stability you
have to
you have to be able to think
independently and you have to be you
have to be
when you come to a conclusion you have
to really not care what other people say
and and just follow the facts and follow
your reasoning and and that's that's
tough for a lot of people
that part i think i was just lucky with
i was born that way
in terms of emotions it's a truism that
investing emotions are your enemy
absolutely that when the market's good
if you feel good don't if you feel bad
you should probably do it right
but uh how uh how how did you uh what
was that extra thing where uh so many
will acknowledge that and yet we saw in
the current crisis they they panicked
why you went into seemingly uh potential
disasters like ge and goldman sachs
i i can't really tell you the i mean i
didn't learn in school or anything i
just it never bothered me if people
disagreed with what i thought
as long as i felt i knew the facts i
mean there's a whole bunch of things i
don't know think about i just stay away
from those so i stay within what i call
my circle of competence today the 18
founders of alibaba a lot of people
think they are legendary so i mean wow
you all ibaba founders you must be super
good at
honestly
most of us cannot find jobs early days
we're not that smart
none of us graduate from a
you know a great university
um
but the thing is that
we are ready to learn
we believe in the future if we work
together if we learn we've improved
we'll be there i told them for the first
year everybody forget about that you
will be vp vice president right you will
always be a tiny manager in your life
because if we're successful
people will high they will be smarter
than us
if we only hire people who are stupid
than us then we'll be in trouble
right so when we hire people who are
smarter than us the company will grow
you will be happy because this is the
mission that we have
so i would say there's no best people in
the world that is suit
ready for you
the best of people is always you you
find the right people
working together
training him developing him and he
training you he
then you have a chance to build a team
as a general matters of one piece of
specific finance
financial advice
i would say you know avoid credit cards
just forget about them
we're in various businesses that issue
credit cards the american public loves
credit cards but if you start revolving
debt on credit cards you're going to be
paying
18 or 20 percent and
you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at 18 or 20
percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at 18 or 20 over time you know if
you can find anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation that's
always behind in life
uh you know i was lucky i'd saved about
ten thousand dollars by the time i got
out of school that ten thousand dollars
was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the expenses roll
in but but those were my tools to work
with but it was only because i was ahead
of the game if you're behind the game by
ten thousand dollars at some point and
paying eighteen or twenty percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it so the trick
i've got a partner that says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there you know and
uh
and that's true in financial matters as
well you want to figure out where you
don't want to be
uh ahead of time and avoid that and i
get about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems
and there are two reasons why they have
terrible problems one is
a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in
they run up bills they can't pay and and
really only society can solve that one
uh in terms of protecting people against
that that's just plain bad luck
but
the other one is from people who run up
credit card debt and they're facing
bankruptcy or they've been through
bankruptcy once before and they owe a
whole bunch of money and they can't they
can't even pay the interest let alone
pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable catastrophic illness is not
but but uh
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better
it's way easier to stay out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and
i will guarantee you if you run a big
credit card that you will be in trouble
uh probably the rest of your life in
terms of uh your financial situation on
the other hand if you get ahead of the
game
uh
even it's on a very modest scale
so that money is coming in from
investing
and you're you're
people owe you money or equities owe you
ownership uh you'll be way out of the
game compared to paying it uh
being always being paying
your creditors every month so my advice
to you is
if you can't pay for it don't buy it the
idea here is look commit
okay and this is the problem with the
schooling system everything's got to be
figured out first i got to read the
instruction first like nobody really
does read the answers i never read the
answer i wrote an article about it i
don't read any instructions you know and
so
i mean i can't i can't read them because
they're so small
so so uh and even when i could read them
i'm like i don't want to read the
instructions can't they make this
simpler yeah so and that is the premise
there yeah can't it just be simpler yeah
and the way to make it simple is and we
see this happening today i mean this is
happening on a global scale where
picking a car up now is simple
pick me up it's crazy i don't have to
put the address in it should locate
where i am
car picks me up i put in the destination
tells guy where to go you don't even
need to pay for it either it's already i
don't have to sit up like simple you
guys got everything should be simplified
and the way to simplify things i
remember mercedes been years ago i heard
about this when they had first figured
out how to put a drop back a hard top
uh convertible into the trunk they had
never they couldn't figure it out it
used to be these old you know they'd
hang them up in the garage and take them
off and it was like very laborious
and somebody at mercedes-benz said
don't tell me what it's going to cost
tell me when it's done
just get it done no matter what this is
how the elon musk are thinking today you
know this is why apple keeps creating a
crazy product while this will go away
somebody's going to come along one day
and say get rid of the phone
and i still want to communicate yeah and
it'll probably be on a headset more like
this we'll probably we'll probably go in
here right where i'm popping i mean the
watches yeah they're they're moving
there right it's crazy
so to where i don't even need a watch i
won't need anything it's like okay i
want to call bye-bye we're moving in
that direction of less and faster and
simpler so the way the human being does
that he's in brisbane that's part of the
gold coast
i got to get down there he's committed
he doesn't figure he he just gets flight
no research
no no you weren't researching it last
night no not at all if you didn't if you
didn't know about this last night you'd
have been you'd have been doing work
about it last night planning negotiating
with the airlines when you get
compressed on time and you got a
commitment you're like i got to be there
at 2 30. everything works out
yeah as i was walking out my assistant
she goes oh where where are you going to
stay
and i was like
booked me a place we're close to you
know to the park or where you're staying
you won't put that out but um we're on
this trip we went to tokyo
because things don't work out as planned
anyway yeah so i'm not saying go through
life unplanned i have 500 employees so
there's got to be some planning there's
got to be is that stretched over it
doesn't need to be me doing the planning
though yeah
like i need maybe i need somebody else
to do that
i don't have to do that no i just need
to know where i want to go so we were
coming to sydney i knew i had this
commitment with success resources to
come here and do these events good tell
me when the events are bang bang bang
um okay i got to get there right so a
week ago i'm like okay hey lanny i
called my pilot uh i want to let route
to sydney but
let's stop in hawaii
uh let's go to kauai
uh kids have never been there we'll stay
there for three days acclimate for a
second and shoot down to sydney i had
enough data to know that i would need to
do a route like that storm comes in
i can't get a i can't for some reason i
can't get a the place i want in kauai
storm comes across the south the pacific
and
uh lanny said hey we might want to be
careful with this storm coming down
there i said okay well let me just let's
reroute to fiji double storm pops up
double-headed cyclone
okay in our path he's like grant we
can't go that way we'd have to go all
the way around this storm i said no we
don't go to tokyo
now the point of that story is look just
keep moving forward keep moving in a
direction that you want to go to we go
to tokyo i made all these friends in
tokyo i would have never done that but i
was committed to going to sydney
and so again commit move in the
direction that gets you closer to where
you're going to go recently you shared
in a press conference
that one of facebook's focuses for the
next decade
is that it is more important to be
understood
than be liked
will you just share what you meant by
that
yeah i mean
look it's
let's be real here i'm not i'm not like
communicating is not my best thing right
um
you know i came out here i've
been planning for this i'm excited about
it and then i messed up the name of our
data center within 30 seconds
so i mean look when when i got started
with facebook i was 19.
and um
and there were so many parts about
building a company that i didn't know
right i didn't i didn't know anything
about hiring or managing or building a
company and i certainly didn't
really know that much about you know how
to
communicate about what we were doing
with the world i mean i'm an engineer by
training right i
i love coding i like building products
that's that's kind of the background
um
and uh
you know my experience you know kind of
growing up and running the company is
you know went out talked about what we
did
say some stupid things get called out
for it and get like kind of go into a
into a shell right and and uh end up
being really cautious about how we
communicate
so
you know it kind of it worked out okay
for a while for the company because
we we built products that a lot of
people really like and you know we
weren't winning because we were
communicating well we were winning
because the products were working well i
think in spite of the fact that we were
communicating quite poorly about what we
were doing but broadly speaking for a
long time
the basic approach was okay let's try to
not like
do anything that's going to be too
offensive right and we'll kind of
explain what we're doing in broad
strokes and talk about the mission of
what we're doing which is something that
i really believe in helping to build
community and and bring people closer
together
but you know i think we just shied away
for a long time talking about some of
the things that
some of the principles that we believe
in that that um that are increasingly
controversial in the world and
i just think that we
for one don't have that luxury anymore
for two uh i i think that that kind of
led for a while to a sentiment towards
the company that was
positive but fairly shallow because if
people if if you're not kind of out
there standing for things that uh that
people care about then it's not possible
for people to feel that strongly about
what you're doing but so now you know i
i've just i've tried to change our
approach more recently you know i went
out and i in georgetown
last year i gave this speech around our
principles around free expression well
to go back to when i started my
partnership in 1956 that berkshire came
out of there were seven people sitting
there at a table
having dinner
relatives primarily and i said here's
the partnership agreement
it's done under nebraska law that's four
or five pages you don't need to read it
but i said here's a little
half page what i call the ground rules
and i want you to read these
and if you feel okay about that
about the interaction what the
expectations are and all of that sort of
thing then we'll join forces and if you
don't it's fine other people have you
know but we don't we shouldn't be
partners i mean you know if i'm gonna
have a partnership with somebody i want
to be compatible it is you know and
when you have a
public company you can't control who
comes in i can't control some guy that
comes in and thinks we're gonna pay big
dividends or split the stock or
something like that so by my actions
and my communications and everything i
want to attract the people
that
from the public market that i want and i
want to keep the others away costco was
built
sal price who started the price club and
that thing
he sat down and figured out the customer
he didn't want and he set up a system
that would keep away the customer didn't
want who did not want he didn't want
somebody buying a quart of milk with
somebody behind them with a
with a basket of 200 worth of goods
waiting for that so we put in a
membership fee and by putting in a
membership page he killed all the drop
in business the business to belong to
the 7-eleven
we want berkshire
to to keep out people who have
expectations about us that are different
than ours i mean
good for them and i hope they find
somebody they said but
if you're going to run a church
you want you want your seats to be
filled by people that are generally want
to listen to your form of religion and
you don't want to change every week and
say gee i need a new group and i'll go
out and talk to a bunch of investors and
get them to come to my church this
sunday because there's only so many
seats in the church there's a million
645 000 or so a equivalent shares and
those are the seats and i want them
occupied by people that are on the same
page i am being an entrepreneur is about
taking risks but it's about taking very
calculated risks and being you know
protecting the downside so i didn't quit
my job selling fax machines
until i had already invented the product
i was working on it at night and on the
weekends for two years i was driving
around north carolina where most hosiery
was made begging a bunch of
manufacturing plants to help make it and
i didn't quit my job until i had already
landed neiman marcus saks fifth avenue
and got a call from oprah
just a typical day
then i was like okay i feel confident to
quit but i needed the income that was
coming in and i needed my health care
benefits and i was working out of my
apartment in virginia highlands and i
ran spanx out of my apartment for two
and a half years
and it was crazy i mean i'd semi trucks
pulling up twice a week to this
apartment and my neighbors were like
what's happening what's going on but i
was so conservative with my finances in
the beginning i was very scrappy and
still am right companies are learning
organisms
and
you can make decisions that either make
it so that you learn faster or you learn
slower and you know in a lot of ways
building a company is like following the
scientific method right you try a bunch
of different hypotheses
and if you set up the experiments well
then you kind of learn what to do and
again that's that's an important
philosophy so there are all these
different decisions that we make inside
the company
you know everything down to
um really empowering individual
engineers we invest in this huge
testing framework right at any given
point in time there aren't there's not
just one version of facebook running in
the world right there's probably tens of
thousands of versions running because
engineers here have the power to um to
try out an idea
and
and and ship it to you know maybe 10 000
people or 100 000 people and then they
get a readout on how uh that version of
what they did whether it was um a change
to you know show better content to news
feed or or ui change or some new feature
they get a readout on how
that version performed compared to the
baseline version of facebook that we
have on everything that we care about
how how connected people are
you know how much people are sharing and
how much they say that they're finding
meaningful content uh business metrics
like how much revenue we make and
engagement of the overall community and
you know by running tens of thousands of
different experiments and putting the
power in people's hands to try all these
different things you can imagine we just
make so much more progress than we could
if every change had to be approved by me
right or any every idea had to come from
from management so i do think there's
something very deep about building this
you know learning culture and moving
quickly towards that that just helps you
get ahead over time the process of me
cutting the feet out of my pantyhose
while trying to get the prototype made
before i launched it was two years so
there was a year solid of me driving in
north carolina on the weekends and at
night or taking time off from work to go
and work on the prototype get it made i
learned so many things that i didn't
know as a consumer it had never dawned
on me you know that men were making all
of our undergarments so i learned very
quickly that the industry had been
taking an average waistband size between
a small
and an extra large and putting the same
waistband on every pair
exactly that's what i said i said you
know
that's not working
we're really uncomfortable and they were
doing it to cut cost and production so i
immediately changed that in a spanx
waistband a size small gets a small
medium gets a medium and so on makes
perfect sense right
i also realized that they had been
putting a tiny rubber cord inside the
waistbands that had been there forever
well we had made so many advancements in
yarns that they no longer needed the
rubber cord but no one had stopped to
say do we still need to put this so i
immediately took the rubber cord out of
it and another thing i learned was the
way that they were doing sizing was just
so blew me away they would figure out a
size by putting them on plastic
forms and they would all put it on a
plastic form they had different size
forms and they would stand back with
their clipboards and go
yep that's a size medium
and i'd lean in and i go
ask her how she feels
so at spanx we put our product on women
my mother my grandmother who's 90
my sister-in-law cassie i mean all of my
friends the girls at spanx we're testing
it on real women and we want to test it
more than two seconds to say yep that
looks like a medium we we have people
wear it for a week wash it tell us if it
rolled did it move did it stay in place
how did you feel very concerned with
spanx garments and how they made you
feel when instead of just holding on to
all of the stock that you got from yahoo
you did what
we call a collar you colored so
you hedged it so tell everybody what
went through your mind because that was
a big bet with huge dollars right and it
was a pr it was actually pretty simple
so you know hedging stock if you know
yahoo paid us in yahoo stock
and
you know i
was smart enough to recognize i guess
that what goes up could go down but it
wasn't that big a step because i was
worth more than a billion dollars how
much did i need right so i was telling
everybody just find me a way to hedge it
so in the event look if the stock price
goes up and i leave something on the
table so be it right but
i like that being next to my name and i
wanted to keep it
and so
i sold calls bought puts and effectively
hedged it so that
by the time so
there was a period of time from when i'd
done that and the internet stock market
kept on going up and and i told people
i'd hedged it and goldman sachs the
company had told people what i'd done
and i remember going on cnbc the
business channel and then the guy going
boy don't you feel stupid that yahoo
stock has kept on going up and you had
this hedge and i'm like yeah i feel so
stupid riding around my g5 that i bought
online you know
and and it was just like
not to sound like a crazy greasy greedy
capitalist but
yeah and it was like
i just didn't want to screw it up and so
i hedged it and then the internet bubble
burst and i was fully protected and
actually even made a little bit more
money and you know middle um
you know the motto that the
you know what i learned was you just you
don't need to be greedy you know i was
very very blessed i was very fortunate
look i didn't plan the internet stock
market to go up and i didn't plan to go
down so i was lucky in terms of scale
and i didn't want to screw it up and so
i hedged the first law is
the third law of motion in physics which
says for every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction and we showed that
very beautifully in the color purple
when messily says to mr everything you
even try to do to me is already done to
you
that is not just a rhetorical saying
that is law that is newton's third law
of motion
in physics which says everything
that goes out is coming back
it's just like everything that goes up
is coming down may take a long time to
come down is coming down
everything that goes out is coming back
it's coming back so
to answer the power of manifestation and
meditation what meditation does is sync
you up with the source
what meditation does is allows you to
literally tap into the power that
created you so that you are in alignment
with that
and so when you carry that out into the
world everything that you do
comes from the center of that alignment
that's coming from the source that we
call god we call divine energy divine
intelligence whatever name you want to
give it we call life when you are synced
up with life
life just gives to you how did you get
through like tactically to a sale in the
encyclopedia world like people don't
want to hear from you so like how do you
overcome that
what a question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days
i was out for three and a half years and
the way it worked in those days it was
commission only so the way it worked is
you went for an interview they told you
all you could possibly make of
commission only and we were in training
for three days it was a presentation
that was scripted we'd have to memorize
the whole thing well when you got in the
field you remember parts of it you knock
on doors you're not quite sure of
yourself a lot of dirts are close in
your face but what happens after a while
you start getting used to it and you see
what you can say or do
that'll make it better but when you go
back the next day with your other sales
people what you see what you do what did
i say
uh so let's say knock on 100 door skin
into one give 10 presentations to sell
one book but then when you get better
and better at it through your
experiences and losses along the way it
sharpens you up where all of a sudden i
got to a point where if i gave three
presentations i have no less than one
order commission only but i believe that
i could do that i believe that colleges
were the best set of books because a
high school student could read it it
wasn't like a college manual you had to
read and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe that
what you're doing is good is going to
benefit somebody and you learn as you go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people know these things look
someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye because you feel
uncomfortable of course you do they're
not on the same wavelength you're under
the same frequency so what do you do how
do you overcome that you learn these
things along the way you look them right
between the eyes or their eyebrows looks
like you're looking over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh there's all these things
and of course smile smile is the most
wonderful thing god gave us and you
don't smile when you first talk to
somebody you smile before you knock on
their door
and if your day sucks you fake it
hi how you doing so when you smile
everything changes people change when i
got to dallas i was a bartender at night
and i moved in one of my buddies from
indiana said you got to come to dallas
and i'm like i'm there you know my car
would only get so far i had a fiat x19
with a hole in the floorboard that
guzzled oil every 60 miles and i went
down there and there's a place called
the village it's the world was the
world's largest apartment complex we had
six guys in a three-bedroom apartment i
didn't have my own room i didn't have my
own drawer i didn't have my closet i had
a pile and i had one ratty towel that i
stole from
motel 6. um and that was it and so i was
looking for my career got a job at the
software store and i was you know
i was didn't have a tech background so i
was teaching myself all this because the
way i look at tech is somebody invents
it
and everybody else is tied for second
place and the ability to learn it and if
if i work harder and faster to really
dive in if it means reading the manual
you know just diving in then i can get a
head start
i was 24.
and so sleeping on the floor working in
a software company you know learning
learning learning learning learning
getting better at what i was doing and
then one day because i was dying to get
out of that rat hole that i lived in um
i had a chance to go out and close the
sale for that would have got me a 1500
commission and so i went to my boss his
name is michael humecki and i said boss
one of my responsibilities was to sweep
the floor wipe down the windows and open
the door to open the store i got the
sale you got to let me close the sale he
goes no you got to be in here to open
the store
and i'm like michael i mean no so i made
the executive decision to go out pick up
the check thinking if i had this guy a
fifteen thousand dollar check
of course he's going to change his mind
fired me on the spot
and so here i was
living in a [ __ ] excuse my french
you know just this ratty place with a
motel six towel sorry motel six um
and
and really didn't know how i was going
to get out but i went to i decided okay
i'm a lousy employee i went to um one of
the companies that i've been talking to
architectural lighting and i said look
um i need 500 to be able to buy the
software you want and i promise you that
even if it doesn't work i will wash your
car you know i will walk your dog i
don't care what it is i would do
whatever it takes to make it up to you
and they gave me the 500 and that
allowed me to create micro solutions and
you know six months later i was out of
the rat hole and my company turned into
a real company and that's the one i sold
um for six million dollars when i was 29
30 years old the last time i was on this
interview
i think i just started working out every
day and my body was hurting all the time
i was in pain constantly you didn't want
to do it you were struggling
dude my ankles hurt my knees hurt my
back hurt my like like i had constant
pain in my body why'd you keep doing it
doing what working out no that that
that's no that i wasn't working before
you started working my body was running
pain i wasn't using my body i didn't use
it and it started to abandon me oh like
i wasn't paying attention to it you know
and it's like okay dude
you don't you don't want to pay
attention to me
i'm going to make you maybe i don't pay
attention to you
you know or maybe i'll make you pay
attention to me yeah and then i got i
went to a pt uh three days a week that
really didn't do anything and i said you
know what i need to take responsibility
for this if i want to fix something that
that that's the code of my life do you
want to fix something take
responsibility yeah you take responsive
don't give it over to the physical
therapist the masseuse i was trying the
masseuse the masseuse never helped me
i needed to put muscle on my bones
so i i hired a guy named anthony he came
i said you come to the you come to my
place every day well when i went back to
china in 1995 with an idea of the
internet was very strange china was not
connected to the internet so i tried to
talk to a lot of my friends that what is
internet nobody say ah this thing never
work
this thing never exists
um
because it's true because nobody but
people even say jack is alive because
he's trying to steal money from people
telling us there is the internet so when
i go to
when i go to the china
red
company registration office
i said i want to register company called
hanzo hope
internet
company
the guy looked at me say
this is the
english dictionary tell me there's no
there's no word called internet why you
want a registered company called the
internet
so i cannot register name a company name
but
it i in
1995 in later
august china was connected the internet
i was number seven person connected to
the in china internet
in order to prove
i was not a lie
i invited my friend who is a tv man
take the tv camera they all stay in my
home
and we
they just try to take the picture i i
died from houngzhou to shanghai shanghai
to america to connect the internet it
took us
three hours and a half to download the
first front of the page
at that time there is no netscape called
the mosaic
oh
so ever i have to make like a hundred
stars to keep my journalists friends to
stay and wait because to prove that i'm
not telling a lie
[Music]
if you want another video on how
billionaires think check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there that's not really how it works if
you don't love it don't expect others
will either your relationship with time
is such a key component
of your life because when you get caught
in a routine
time goes so quickly